Savannah Chrisley shares a heartbreaking
text from her little sister Chloe amid
their mom Julie's first Mother's Day in
prison I'm helping to raise my 10 year
old sister and 16 year old brother on
Monday the reality star shared this
screenshot to her insta story a text
from Chloe reading I'm sad mom will not
be here for Mother's Day Savannah
captioned the message the things no one
talks about we need to figure out
healthier ways to cope with things and
deal with things and even if it's just
little things that I'm trying to
implement because I'm not their mom I'm
not their dad I'm I'm their sister look
any family who faces a loved one going
to prison it's a very difficult
challenge but they're strong they're
faithful Julie and her husband Todd are
serving a combined 19-year sentence
following their convictions for bank
fraud and tax evasion if Todd and Julie
could share a message with the world
what do you think they'd want them to
know I think they'd want folks to know
that they are the same people they've
always been and that they're going to
fight to get their name clear because
God didn't bring us this far to drop us
off the two surrender to prison in
January
I know how I feel going through this
trauma I cannot imagine how two kids
feel going through it I have raised
thanking children right and so I for
that I'm blessed Savannah has been open
about the challenges of raising Chloe
and her 16 year old brother Grayson in
their parents absence the other night I
just had a full on breakdown and was
trying to find Chloe proper clothes to
go and visit my parents and find her
hair stuff and I just sat down on the
floor and just started crying with Chloe
and Grayson I'm like you know what they
need to see peace and calmness Chloe's
10 years old and I know that she's on TV
at certain times but outside of that I
think it's probably the best that Chloe
be allowed to grow up as any other 10
year old would Chloe is actually Todd
and Julie's granddaughter the child of
Todd's son Kyle from a previous marriage
and Chloe she is just precious as can be
she's the boss she truly is she is the
boss they obtained custody amid Kyle
struggles with addiction I have
officially raised children my entire
life and just I was that close to a
clean getaway and then all of a sudden
here comes my club bug knocking on the
door we're starting over and Chloe she
thinks her big sis is doing A-Okay
watching over her we were in the car and
she was like you're doing a pretty good
job
to me
[Music]
I had a conversation with my dad and he
was like you know what Savannah this is
going to be the hardest but most
rewarding thing you've ever done
and I'm starting to see that
[Music]